[Music]
chilis are a fabulous ingredient
and one of my absolute favorites is the
chipotle
chipotles begin life as a green jalapeno
pepper the process of drying and smoking
lends an intense smoky flavor to balance
their spicy heat
dried chipotles can be brought as a
paste powder
or whole which is how i'll be using them
in my big bold lunch
chilis come in all shapes and sizes and
heats and are used throughout the world
but if there's one cuisine that has
really turned cooking them into an art
form
it's mexican they're experts at building
layer upon layer flavoured with
delicious chilies and spices so for my
ultimate big and bold lunch
spicy mexican soup it's hearty delicious
robust but served with some tortillas
and a wonderful salsa
it's almost like a complete meal in one
starting with some finely chopped red
onions for my soup
let's get some heat going early these
are chipotle so they're
smoky rich they don't come with any
warning signal and these are seriously
hot
so be adventurous but beware
a nice teaspoon of toasted cumin
oregano dried now start frying off
spices the heat you'll see the
chilies start swelling up delicious
garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili
right now those onions and garlic are on
fire
we're going to balance the sort of heat
from the chipotle with
sugar turn up the heat and really start
caramelizing that sugar
and the chili gives off the most amazing
aroma next fry up a tablespoon of tomato
puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes cooked
kidney beans
and vegetable or chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be
somewhat controlled you can't go crazy
so
cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release
chilies particularly when they're dried
continue to swell and release their heat
as they're cooked
so the longer you cook your dish the
hotter it will be
[Music]
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet and every five
six seven eight minutes that's gonna get
stronger hotter
and more delicious bring that up to the
ball and cook that out
for 15 minutes whilst i allow the chilli
heat to infuse
i'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa
known in mexico as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deceeded fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion then chop a good
handful of fresh coriander
add the juice from two limes salt and
pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop bought
wheat wraps sprinkle with smoked paprika
and gently massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees
until golden brown and leave to cool
to complete my mexican lunch i need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
the spice is there it is absolutely
spot on now for the cooling down process
the mexicans are brilliant at building
layer upon layer of flavor with
delicious chilies and spices
but they're also experts at tempering
their dishes with cooling ingredients
like avocado sour cream and cheese
that's why you can take that amount of
chilli you've got a spoon of richness
spice and all of a sudden avocados
almost like a little fire blanket
over those chilies to further counter
the chilli heat
mexicans use a rich tangy crumbly cheese
but i'm sprinkling on lancashire
which is a great british substitute
and last but not least cooling fresh
coriander
one delicious spicy mexican soup
serve that with your tortilla chips and
your pico de gallo
salsa a phenomenal blend of
textures and layers and spice and
creaminess big
bold and delicious spicy mexican eggs
this is a very classic mexican style
brunch dish
bold kick-ass flavors slice the chili
seeds in garlic sliced
nice and thinly a tablespoon of olive
oil
i'm a big fan of brunches and if you get
it right a great brunch can see you
right through to dinner
now to start the sort of spicy fragrant
tomato sauce
get your cumin in there garlic chili
roasted cumin red onions already sounds
mexican
once that starts getting really nice and
crispy in
with your tomatoes never embarrassed
using
good canned tomatoes i do all the time
cooking at home
now by reducing that you sort of come
down to a delicious paste
leave that to simmer next canned beans
called black beans
these are authentically mexican but
cannellini beans or chickpeas will work
just fine
just rinse them a little bit of water
that
is beautiful turn off the gas and just
let it absorb
leaving the dense beans to luxuriate in
the spicy tomato sauce will allow them
to soften and soak up
all the flavor next
oil and season an oven-proof dish from
my spicy egg brunch to baking
i'll just get some of that oil round the
outside
take your corn tortillas slice them in
half
and then just stick them to the side
these are a staple in mexico
take one and place that in the center
get your mix and place that on top of
the tortilla
spread that out nice and smoothly lift
up those little
flaps i want that crisp shell on the
outside
now your eggs and cheese get the base of
the egg
and just make a little hole in there and
then crack
the egg into there again use a little
point
put your egg in there one two
three four five and one in the middle
gently crack and get the egg to sit
inside
almost like it's a little dug out and
then one for the center
get a really nice rich delicious strong
montgomery cheddar
i want to grate the tortilla shell as
well so get generous with it
on the top i'm gonna season that with
these little babies
little chili flakes they're my little
secret weapon and they're going to spice
up that egg
just salt a touch of pepper
sip that in the oven to bake for eight
to ten minutes and 180.
[Music]
[Applause]
that smells incredible it's a little bit
of coriander to finish it off
and that for me is what brunch is all
about let's go
a fantastic fiery brunch to get your
party started
spicy mexican eggs and a crispy tortilla
shell